ви давайте себе інформаційну програму
д.в.
нові не вітай у вас була поза темою
сьогодні куди йдуть біженці після
перекриття
угорського кордону як вставлятися в
дніпропетровську dota за новим
перейменування місця такі новинки прав
польського автосалону може виражатися в
україну
панщина практично воно злочинне для
біженців маже 200 кілометрові parkan
з колючого дро тут у даній на кордоні
алайхі бац і зуб інших мігрантів цих же
де сталося з близько сходу до Європи
біжіть чи знаєш шлях popsugar шини у
team на ньому краще мало париж код
мін ще за вишилася об під і куди сиф
видний на балканах з іммігрантам здалося
нелегально перед multi-core донцю борщ
іншу ви зниження джалив тій ось друзі
вала сюди з іраку ми вже в
дорозі 15 16 днів у вигляді чорні тузи та
ніл та овочами сім'я
мігрантам майже охолонула чогось не просив і
вид підшиті білизни будинку іштвана міксе
кілочки їх впустити втомимося і дня ми
документ багатієм біженцями кіпру ходили
по взводу милку розуму наймають зубних
проблем із біженцями
я не фашист і можеш же ти зніми плече
притч алое і в нас люди і кима ці
проти південної думки вона Віталіна Хендера
біженці прокла дала собі шлях у західну
Європу через Італію Грецію то у Вощину
а запис готова куварзина прикрила
кордон сербію і супроводила поки що раніше
за нього на легальний паритет біженці
через сербію йдуть до хорватії
щоб потім праворуч ти про клас ти шлях
далі ми хочемо стрибнути на кордон з
хорватією у
щуп дали виріс що в західну Європу
мучилася чого вощина відвезли на 3 роки
забороною кордону думав брала хорватію
кордон імідж хорватію це серверні обл.
1 на і жадібними обгороджені
сербсько влада організувала автобуси та
cavid возять мігрантів на хорватську
кордон by 6 біженців не доходить до про
кордон їх пустив з varta youtube оля
дійдуть фішки до хорватії
я поведу мало сербські змі у хорватії
біженці може на трап і таємницями не куля
віку втратила від шосе провини на
балканах дев'яностих руках
воювали буду живий там і лисина шляху
ми не знаємо їх чавла дацик raindrop та
динамимо щоб додому будь на веденому
від них годинникам у прибиральники не посилала на
патрулює кордон сербію
новачок че кому не вдалося його парить
ти біженців завтра від нього
середині країни та акції haute couture
зування стану
видно із законом і вощини їм завантажуючи вагу
на яйця
процес декомунізація в Україні
проходить в активну фазу за два
місяця березень перейменувати і близько до
500 сил-то місць обидва хотів знак живе був
та себе граматики обговорення лідером з
переманювання мої статті дніпропетровська
область
Яким та кому не знати все на думку
німецьких експертів травня привести до
переосмисленням нової кишені України
женеві здійснюється цех дніпропетровську
я пхав нашу cross pendant як сандрою
духова мешканці дніпропетровська вадим
шибанов втомиться і в руку бореться за
перейменування своє горить на них-то
дніпропетровськ бум названий над 6
троянського революціонера та партії нам
ідеї дж алегорія петровського на донку
Вадима місця не винна мото нічого
спинно кохану річку в Україні
поважають одним зайняти atari у голодоморах
за моєю сім'єю прапорщика голодомор
пройшовся по моїй батьківщині той самий син
маніпулі не та та та по лінії матері та я
постраждали я за парою ману вання
повернення місць у нас у дні назва
дніпро видно законами про декомунізацію
кіно було цінності на прикиньте травня в
україні maite будуть для іменування місця
там вулиці з радіо низьким названі
найбільше мешканці місця схалявити їжа
завищену дорогою назвати не про сир від
кращих кандидатів на свої місця не
послав новий кодек не просить зараз лал
купа багатих цього знання що вже своїх
до дніпропетровська
всі числа всі числа ми знаю я в
людина пух податківцю
але не дніпропетровська петрів я не я
ніколи комуністам алея проти
перемелювання місця дніпропетровськ
немає ні про град ми не буду бійці назва
до кінця віри з ними старого будинку іноді
ти свій пропустіть щось нове на свої
місця у верховній раді як і
затвердіти свою та кому не зайти
дніпропетровська розхитавши задовго до
затвердження закону про судини чи то
тарного комуністичного режиму Польщі
пам'ятник леніну знесли тут ще у лютому
2014 року нині біля дніпропетровськ місяця
завершилася ажурна пам'ятка леніну до
sweet європейських краги ну тому що з
ними машини
здійснити процес переосмислення манув
його ним уже проходить легко то дозволь з
на декомунізація моя дізнатися шото не
просто про ім'я місце вулиць а самий
простий ми йшли не так що ти хочеш жити в
демократичній Україні з демократичною
відтягнуся теми she's ось and і щоб твої
місця та його посмішці на цілий при здачі
нічим тоталітарному режиму радянське
минуле райан sky moon вул а вона була
травматичним для України і багато
сьогоднішніх нас багато mefik та keeps ще
і снують розумієте буду подала не гавкають
вони мають бути пасмами відокремлені тому
ми тут же важливий процес і можна його
тихими то ти за крима такі аспекти і
відкриття архіві розтин стригти
відомості історичні дослідження на
думка активіста води ваші банного
україна мало раз купа то процес
дегуманізації ще тисяча дев'ятсот
дев'яносто першому уроці відразу після
провалу надійності кінця до них і
чини ангела меркель вчать вирве create a
face кований автолюбителям а
міжнародний автосалон у франкфурті
продати не можна весь дізнаємося це все з
експонатами салону малий і журналісти там
був і наш спеціальний кореспондент
в'ячеслав Юрін за його сюжетом про вона і
Престижні прем'єри таки може стати
аккаунт для українського ринку
c та франкфуртський автосалон впоралися та
льоту для шин овальних і в кросовері
і в класі з і вид і пір'я новий бос
первинний лідер bentley bentley гам і
тесту метушня пількера sketch нога
оснащенням купа бантингу але одні
платформі з audi q7 новим коза дає він з
технічної точки зору максимально
шведки секунд це 300 кілометрів за роки
ну у русі це в україні праски я з you
via всі шанси стати на цю популярну
моделі bentley
нові з juve вже можна замовити
стартова ціна близько 200 тисяч євро
свою відповідь на banggood у них і
rolls-royce що правда розруб до моделі
за вболівальники чи караоке афішу чи не
всі роллс-ройси тільки одна новинка
кабріолет дон на базі copyright borgward
цілий бурштиновий німецький бренд текке знак
натомість pit fatality атомом відро джон і
за допомогу і китайського концерну фотон
перше муліне these вивісять ви чай наш
кросовер випускати її з juve розміром
з audi q5 будуть у китаєм через 2 руки
планують раз патча ти продаєш в
європе аллах їжу тягу borgward прайда до
україни за ринком ще розвивається а я
майже до України тарусі
вибуху листя на хочу роботою ви нитки
професіонали жити до крейн за ринком
ще розвиваються
Аліна новинки не будемо а виходять і
надходило послугу його у баби провернула
що одна новинка на ринку з юрієм ягуар
представив у франкфурті свою пошту
моделлю тему класика вранці мало назву
fps в автомобілі захід страху приватним
дизайном я не було жодного шансу на успіх
старий odnoklassniki почуття suites on a
beach популярних курсів рифту прем'єру
франкфурті та квітки всю вікі про спорт
Алеппо за конкуренцію на автосалоні
буксер volkswagen tiguan
автомобіль підірвати лише of designs to
у динамічному та агресивному че bloody
інші покоління кросовера випуску ти
по суті з України та в Росії, що
відкрито через дах
відомствами чоловік сплив і рішення на
еблище месительці будуть дильна
лайкайте мою митися роботи в чині
ці колонки в класі представлені
лімузині в нові стандарти usb і ви
просто не цифрових технологій задає
апельсинка бмв
його головний конкурент та концерн daimler
провісів франкфурт кабріолет із класу
такою моделлю лінуйтеся та konsert але
тут штутгарта не було вже польоту 40
рокки мінімальна ціна харчування але це
100 тисяч євро
ситуацію в сирії то постачанням разів бренду
москва плану і він говорить і
прем'єр-міністр ізраїлю біньямін
нетаньяху смуток свого візиту до Москви
тему продовжимо, а виглядай новим
прем'єр-міністр ізраїлю біньямін
нетаньяху 20 пройшов виріс на платити за
робочим візитом до Москви за крим і
голова вугілля думаючи номер обговоріть з
президентом Росії Володимиром Путіним
розширення російської злочинності в
сирі і раніше влада США вигляд крила про
позицію Росії обіцяє і нову коаліцію
для боротьби сторожів стану групова
ісламська іржава вашингтон за клік алмаз
cuz you проти ти вже на явну quality
і у нью-йорку проходить 70 а генеральної
асамблеї він і часто сів у говорять
засіки
ризиковий конфлікт в Україні тест рівня
міжнародного трибуналу з розслідування
катастрофи рейсу mh17 на донбасі як по
видам у пустельний підставних українах
він пан від 60 crying вони є в організації
поважає вони орхідні обмаже його щурів
таня права у цю начебто specs він
світлові банк виділить києву критий тупил
мільярда доларів вантажник йдуть на
оздоровлення банківської системи до
стабілізації фінансового сектора країни
святого та банку за ікла ходять україни
при скоро ти реформи міжнародний
олімпійський комітет кут осі у
претендентів на проведення літніх
олімпійських ігор 2024 руку з опариш
hamburg los angeles
будапешт другим гамбург мужів мереж на
висунутий свою контору та громада
референдумі виступали
мешканці місця проголосують за проведення
олімпіади
у курів левської академії місць та лондоні
відкривається виставка ретроспектива а
єврея на ній покажіть роботи китайської
художника дисидента за астану 20 років
17 виріс нього його обирається провести
перформанс на піт ринку біженців навмисне
у світлі відома і китайський художник
жовтнева очі ти ми про берлінське
університеті
а давно ви на прощаєтеся до завтра наша
добра плошайте створені